the first guest i want to bring on is a
friend of mine that we haven't done this
before but
she's got a new book out that i want to
talk to her about uh please welcome
mandy johnson
manday and she's odd just like that
thank you for being here
thanks for having me for people who
don't know you you're you're a
successful comedy producer in in los
angeles you host uh
really one of the best indie shows that
there is or just
show period and you've recently put out
a book
called super serious and oral history of
los angeles independent
stand-up comedy here's the book right
here and
you sort of capture this time in
l.a stand up in the indie scene from
from your show
mixed with uh with portraits they get
that right
yeah sounds like a thing you did great
you did great
yeah very upset i didn't book the cover
you know uh the publishers the
publishers picked the cover
truly yeah sent me a handful and uh
that one just felt fitting it was very
silly was it something that you
that you always wanted to do is to put
out a book or
was it just like well i have all this
stuff and i mean this has to go
somewhere
i mean i think every photographer on
some level always wants to put out a
book you know eventually
uh the portrait series definitely didn't
start out to be a book
it didn't start out to be as big as it
was as it is
now but as it kind of grew bigger and
bigger around
like year six of the show um
people started asking me if i was gonna
do a book and then it kind of took
another
couple years to find a book agent and
sell it and do all the things
i definitely did not know it was going
to be a book had i known her
been a book i probably would have chose
a different face
because you would tell people to do one
of two things before the show would
start
hey take a silly one and then we'll do a
serious
one to go along with the show that
you're curious so
there's there's some great photos in
here there's some beloved people in here
uh our own conan o'brien makes an
appearance in the book
he does it's very fun nicole buyer
great friend people have some very funny
whimsical shots here look at this even
anthony jeselnik
has shown off his slap stick
then we get to the sad white man page
that i find myself on my depression era
photo
you know you're being very serious
you're taking the serious prompt
seriously moses and i appreciate that
took it very serious my whole family
just died of cholera
and famine even even matt broner
no known goof yeah you guys end up in
serious you're
doing it correct yeah i think you nailed
it i
i feel great even known camajin neil
brennan looks
a little bit happier than me yeah he
like turned those slightly you guys did
a nice proper
like head-on you know and yeah i like it
took the note too well uh it's really
cool because what i really liked about
the book
i mean part of it is like you're
nostalgic just to see your friends in
comedy because we're all locked down
right now
but there's there's great interviews in
here a lot of comedians that
people would know are in this book and
it's really cool for us
to have because it's so it's this
closest thing that we have to a yearbook
yeah it's really it's very fun i mean i
didn't
think if we were going to be in a
pandemic when uh we scheduled the time
the book was going to come out
uh we were trying to time it close to
just the ten year of the show which
didn't happen because of the pandemic
but
yeah it's been nice i think to have it
during this time
where we all can't be together and we
can have a little bit of
pre-pandemic comedy like memorializing
history forever
so yeah it's a little sad way to put it
but
but yeah i get it it was really nice to
to read through it
to see friends in in the book and just
kind of remind
of us the time that we really love and
that hey it's still out there
eventually so it did make it a little
easier that one day in quarantine
like oh yeah these are all the people in
here
was there any interview in the book that
that surprised you of like someone that
maybe do the show
um they didn't think was going to do the
show or talk to you for the book
no i think pretty much everyone did chat
with me i really loved carrying
kel gareth's interview um i thought her
interview was really great because she
i think her time kind of in and out of
the scene when she took a break when she
was
for work stuff you know she has a
different perspective on the value of it
um i also think that kind of having the
range of
veteran comedians like andy kindler and
karen have been around since like the
80s to
younger comics like you were interviewed
for the book you know who've been around
l.a for less time than that kind of it's
a nice to show like the expansiveness
of the scene and how it kind of like
ebbs and flows to fit
however many comedians need it to fit
and it kind of morphs around what comedy
needs
so it was an interesting thing to learn
about as i interviewed people
it's really cool and i would highly
recommend the book not just because i'm
in it
in that it does exactly what you said
and then it mixes those those two things
where it's
seasoned comics with very new people
it's the same thing you did with your
live shows where i could go up with
people that i
grew up watching and and you know have
to follow them
and it's the same thing with the book of
people that are you know just new to
comedy
like we're in a book now
you're a comedian yes the best
representation of independent comedy
is that and as big cities where those
comedians live
everybody starts to work on material and
the best place to do it a lot of times
is independent shows because there's
just more of them than the clubs
and those audiences are more patient
because they pay less money
and more into seeing the process a lot
of times so that's great
i think you captured a really great
thing in the book
yeah yeah super serious an oral history
of los angeles independent comedy mandy
thank you so much for
for being here and for making us a
yearbook officially
thanks for having me moses it's good to
see you thanks mandy bye
bye that's mandy johnson grab the book